now a criminal gang behind the latest
massive
ransomware attack is demanding 70
million
dollars in cryptocurrency this hack has
exploited vulnerabilities in management
software made by usit firm
corsair had infected thousands of
computers in at least
17 countries most of swedish grocery
chain
co-ops 800 stores were forced to close
on friday
after the attack blocked access to its
at checkouts
cyber security experts are linking it to
an affiliate of the russian
are evil gang best known for extorting
11 million dollars from meatpacker jbs
in may
we can take a closer look at this with
uh ponder chimbula
uh from dw business who's been following
this story welcome ed japonda
so what are these uh am i saying that
right are evil is that or is it revel
i think it's pronounced evil evil oh i
prefer our evil but we'll go with what
you say rival well are these real people
holding hostage that companies would pay
70 million
dollars to get back well apparently uh
qazia has said that 40 companies were
targeted or were actually reached in
this attack and
essentially what rival or revel whatever
you want to call it
has done is what they did or the people
affiliated with revel
they took data from these companies
encrypted it and now they're holding on
to it so basically they have information
that these companies might need for
their you know regular runnings and
operations
and they're holding on to it until they
are paid 70
million dollars which is basically the
ransom so they are holding on to this
data
as um you know as a like as a hostage
right basically okay so and this is this
is a big deal so big in fact that us
president joe biden
has weighed in on this let's hear from
him and come back to you
the fact is that the director of the
intelligence community
give me a deep dive on what's happened
and i'll know better tomorrow and if it
is uh either with the knowledge of and
or
a consequence of russia then i told
putin we will respond
all right that sounds serious um
chipotle chimbula tell us more then
about
the people behind this attack well it is
said to be an affiliate of
revel which was involved in the colonial
pipeline attack
and also the jbs one and in those both
in those
ransomware attacks the companies that
were involved paid the ransoms
so obviously this next one which is much
higher significantly higher than the 11
million dollars that jbs had paid would
be of course
a surprise and so that's why it is
attractive perhaps for these companies
and gangs
to uh get more you know as much as they
can
in terms of money and they are from
russia supposedly at least
in the first cases they were and experts
are saying that it is a russian gang
affiliated with revel
that is involved in this attack of
course it points
to the methods used and um also
the payment they're asking for a payment
in bitcoin which is similar to
what happened in those two huge attacks
in may as well
with colonia pipeline early may and jbs
at the end of may
yeah let's talk about those because i
mean you mentioned the colonial pipeline
the
the jbs we've had uh whole cities and
municipalities are closed down by these
cyber attacks
are we seeing more of them and and what
if so why
well obviously we rely heavily on um
computer infrastructure and software and
a lot of that software is in the cloud
in terms of the attack that we've seen
which has affected like 40 companies in
17 countries what you have is
essentially
these companies are using a software
that is provided by
quesa when these ransom um
open these hackers basically when they
target
certain vulnerabilities that means they
can you know reach
a bigger group of people because of
course that old companies that software
is not specific to
one company it's specific to more than
one user
and that makes it easier another another
reason is of course the pandemic people
working from home
and then there's of course
vulnerabilities even if you have like an
anti
virus software in on your home computer
uh it's easy to exploit that because of
course there's different networks that
are involved as a result of that so
those are all vulnerabilities that are
also happening as a result of the
pandemic okay chiponda
shambulu from dw business thank you
you